[Music]
a great documentary makes us question
everything if the jurors had known
what we discovered they never could have
found him guilty things you can't unsee
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
hours of interviews someone who's
different from us but also not that
different from us this movie is
absolutely a reason for me to get sober
and to stay sober documentaries show us
the worst and the best
what human beings are capable of we try
to be as respectful as possible to the
people we interview and that's the job
this is hbo docs club where we dive deep
into the true stories that captivate our
imaginations i'm brittany luce long time
documentary super fan freelance
journalist and cultural critic you may
know me from my other podcasts for
colored nerds and the nod and i'm ronald
young jr audio producer storyteller film
critic and cultural commentator you
might have heard me on the podcast
solvable and npr's pop culture happy
hour on each episode of hbo docs club we
take a closer look at a film or series
in the hbo documentary films catalog
we'll get updates on the stories talk
with the filmmakers behind each feature
documentary as well as experts who help
us make sense of what we've seen
sometimes they'll be from our recent
past other times they'll be brand new
but they'll all inevitably teach us
something about the human condition this
season we'll be watching stories about
unsolved child murders the citizens of
atlanta are going to have to take our
community back big political scandals
oliver north and shredded documents to
protect other people and avoid
consequences i understand that perfectly
we'll meet the transgender woman who
tried to revolutionize the auto industry
you catch things on the rising tide
you're doomed to success and get inside
the story of harlem's legendary apollo
theater
[Music]
okay this sounds like a fantastic
podcast brittany honestly i would listen
to this even if this wasn't my job
[Music]
the first episode of hbo docs club
premieres on march 21st and our first
documentary of the season is atlanta's
missing and murdered the lost children
the never before seen look at the tragic
killings in the city too busy to hate
you can watch right now on hbo max and
be sure to subscribe to hbo docs club
wherever you get your podcasts so you
can know what we're watching next
[Music]
you